CBS News has confirmed that New York
Congressman George Santos faces criminal
charges and is expected to turn himself
in later today the Freshman Republican
is admitted to telling phony stories
about his background and qualifications
during his campaign the justice
department has been investigating his
finances Caitlin Huey Burns is on
Capitol Hill Caitlin good morning so
what do we know about these charges good
morning Vlad will the specific charges
are unknown as they remain under seal
but we will learn more about them later
today when the congressman is expected
to appear in court in New York
Thursday yep after months of legal
scrutiny over George Santos's finances
Federal prosecutors filed charges
against the congressman in the eastern
district of New York well there's a
clock ticking renewing calls from many
of his New York Republican colleagues to
resign George Santo should have resigned
in December he should have resigned in
January he should have resigned
yesterday and maybe he'll resign today
but sooner or later honesty and Justice
will be delivered to him Santos is at
the center of several investigations the
FBI is probing his pet charity and the
Securities and Exchange Commission
inquired about his work for Harbor City
capital a financial firm that was
running a Ponzi scheme and in March the
house Ethics Committee opened an
investigation into Santos's Financial
disclosure forms and whether he violated
Federal conflict of interest laws how
can you effectively do your job in
January Santos removed himself from
committee assignments and was defiant
very confident that you will be cleared
yes I am why investigation
Santos was notably absent from house
floor voting Tuesday night and speaker
Kevin McCarthy suggested support for the
Freshman congressman is limited if he's
found guilty if a person is indicted
they're not on committees they have the
right to vote but they have to go to
trial
to take
now we saw comment from Santos directly
as well as from his attorney and his
Congressional office and did not receive
a response but as for the congressmen
before all of this he appeared to be
moving ahead business as usual just
earlier this month Tony he had announced
his bid for re-election
we'll see how that goes Caitlin thank
you very much